hay algo personal que necesito compartir
con todos soy futbolista y soy gay
yo estaba lo quiso contar el mismo al
mundo que es homosexual un anuncio poco
común dentro del fútbol de élite en
especial entre aquellos jugadores que
como él siguen en activo tiene 21 años
es centrocampista del adelaide united de
la primera división del fútbol
australiano y dijo estar cansado de
esconder su identidad ahora
quiero inspirar y mostrar a la gente que
está bien ser tú mismo y jugar al fútbol
está bien ser gay y jugar al fútbol
y
quiero demostrar a todos aquellos que
están pasando por dificultades que
tienen miedo a quien quiera que seas no
actúes como alguien que no eres sé tú
mismo estás destinado a ser tú mismo te
veías auth cabalo juega en su equipo
desde febrero de este año y dijo
sentirse apoyado por sus compañeros su
entrenador elogió la decisión acabe
demorar no puedo estar más orgulloso de
él por la manera en la que ha manejado
esto y la manera en la que ha entregado
el mensaje en tu méndez en ese ojo ha
sido tremendo y todo el crédito es para
george el coraje que ha mostrado son
figuras del mundo del fútbol como gerard
piqué y antoine griezmann de la liga
española o los ex futbolistas ingleses
rio ferdinand y yale lineker han
respaldado acabado atrás que hay uno de
los presidentes más recordados si es el
caso del antiguo internacional de
alemania thomas hitzlsperger quien
disputó el mundial de 2006 con la
selección germana y expeller dio a
conocer que era gay en 2013 un año
después de su retiro profesional